le président ukrainien a tenu ce
discours devant le Capitole devant les
élus américains il a été ovationné comme
rarement un responsable politique
étranger elle a été oui ça fait partie
clairement des bons moments importants
dans ce contexte de guerre ou le
président donc d'un pays en guerre
volody murielski se rend devant le
Congrès de son principal soutien et son
principal allié c'est pour ça aussi que
le président Zelenski n'est pas allé à
Berlin à Paris ou à Londres il est allé
directement
vers le pays qui est quand même le
soutien le plus et puis évidemment
l'image était forte aussi c'est un peu
le Congrès américain c'est un peu le
temple de la démocratie donc il y avait
ce message là aussi porté à la fois
d'ailleurs par le président zellenski et
le président Biden c'est-à-dire la
guerre qui est en cours c'est pas
simplement une guerre entre l'Ukraine et
la Russie c'est aussi une guerre entre
des pays autoritaires voir totalitaires
et tout le monde démocratique qui défend
ses valeurs de liberté à travers la
planète entière et c'est pourquoi en
fait le soutien américain à l'Ukraine
est aussi important est-ce que cette
accueil reçu par volodime ski
signe que les critiques les réserves
qu'on a pu entendre dans le camp
républicain ont été balayés alors en
tout cas il y avait de part et d'autre
de la part de Paulo diverselski et de
Joe Biden un intérêt à ce timing
pourquoi maintenant tout simplement
parce que pour volody mirzelanski
l'hiver début de juste ça va être une
période très difficile parce que les
Russes ont continué à bombarder les
villes et les infrastructures
énergétiques de l'Ukraine donc il vient
aussi à Washington pour dire il faut
absolument que vous poursuiviez votre
aide et que vous nous aidiez absolument
sécurisé notre ciel on vient on vient de
l'entendre même si l'aide déjà fournie
permet quand même aux Ukrainiens de
détruire les trois quarts des missiles
russes qui tombent sur l'Ukraine mais ce
n'est pas
soi-disant donc il faut faire plus d'où
le remerciement effectivement sur le
fait que ce sont les missiles patriotes
très efficaces comme bouclier
antimissiles qui sont donnés enfin par
les Américains et puis pour Joe Biden il
y avait aussi un intérêt à le recevoir
maintenant parce que dans une dizaine de
jours le 3 janvier le Congrès américain
va changer de couleur c'est les
républicains donc qui vont dominer la
Chambre des Représentants et on sait que
chez certains élus républicains
commencent à avoir une réticence sur
cette aide à l'Ukraine qui coûte quand
même très cher qui a déjà écouté 50
milliards de dollars là il y a une aide
de 2 milliards de dollars dans le
missiles patriotes la batterie missile
patriote qui a débloqué et d'ici la fin
de la semaine mais les négociations sont
encore en cours il faut développer une
nouvelle aide massive de 45 milliards de
dollars et certains élus républicains
disent ça commence à faire beaucoup ça
commence à faire très cher donc Joe
Biden sait que à partir du 3 janvier
font démocrate sera en minorité il faut
absolument qu'il embarque avec lui
quelques élus républicains pour que
cette aide américaine se poursuive en
faveur de l'Ukraine au même moment hier
Bruno un autre président se mettait en
scène à 8000 km de lames à Moscou
Vladimir Poutine avait réuni le staff de
ces armées et là aussi il a tenu un
discours guerrier on l'écoute
début janvier la frégate amiral gorge
coffre sera en état de service avec de
nouveaux missiles zircon qui je le
répète n'ont pas d'équivalent dans le
monde
nous continuerons à équiper nos forces
stratégiques d'armes dernier cri je le
répète tous nos plans seront menés à
bien de manière certaine
nous continuerons à maintenir et à
améliorer la préparation au combat de
notre triade nucléaire
voilà Bruno la réponse russe aux
engagements américains pris devant
volodimeersky oui par ailleurs
d'ailleurs la porte-parole du ministère
ou des Affaires étrangères a estimé que
le fait que les États-Unis fournissent
le missile anti-missile patriote aux
Ukrainiens constitué un développement
dangereux qui aurait des conséquences
très graves et inestimable j'ai plus le
terme exact en tête mais enfin
sous-entendu les Russes vont réagir on
ne sait pas exactement comment toujours
est-il que effectivement Vladimir
Poutine devant son encadrement militaire
a voulu montrer que effectivement la
guerre allait se poursuivre outre les
mesures qu'on a entendues là il annonce
que au total il compte portait l'effort
de guerre russe en terme d'effectif à un
million et demi de soldats on est
actuellement un million 150000
il y a les soldats qui ont déjà été
mobilisés qui sont encore en formation
il y en a 150 000 en formation
visiblement il veut encore accroître cet
effort la vraie question c'est est-ce
que c'est faisable est-ce que c'est
possible
tu trouveras suffisamment de monde
est-ce qu'il y aura suffisamment
d'équipements notamment en munitions on
a eu un peu l'impression en fait on
creux que Vladimir Poutine tenait un
discours de guerre très irrulent pour
remobiliser ces troupes et reconnaisser
ainsi un peu aussi les les échecs de ces
derniers mois de l'armée russe et il a
grandi un peu comme d'habitude j'allais
dire la menace nucléaire mais sans en
dire tellement plus que d'habitude en
disant que la triade nucléaire devait
être continué à être activé voilà mais
c'est ça c'est c'est une rhétorique
assez habituelle pour essayer de de
faire peur à l'ennemi mais ce qui
ressort de de cette double séquence en
fait finalement qui s'est déroulée à
Washington et à Moscou et c'est pas
quand même une bonne nouvelle c'est que
cette guerre va durer et que pour le
moment les solutions de négociation les
solutions diplomatiques qui continuent à
être prôné notamment par le président
français Emmanuel Macron et bien on en
est loin Emmanuel Macron lui-même en
convient d'ailleurs et que pour un bon
moment et bien c'est un peu oui c'est un
peu la guerre ou la mort et qu'il n'y a
pas d'espace pour qu'une négociation
puisse s'engager tellement les termes de
cette négociation pour le moment ne sont
absolument pas trouvables entre crayon
et russes